people are defending Trump a lot of
people are outraged by the obvious
Injustice and one of those people leads
a group that I'm I'm not allowed to I
don't think I'm allowed to say it on the
air probably not even allowed to say it
in a private company even though it's
it's a word that has a soft R not a hard
R so it's a word that you hear in the
popular culture so I'm just going to say
Ninjas for Trump is the group that he
leads a lot of supporters going down
into Fulton County expressing their
support for Trump as he was booked last
night well
here is to my mind I'm not being ironic
or sarcastic in any way here is one of
the most articulate defenses of trump
and clear-eyed views of political
philosophy I have heard from a viral
character in years
I'm here to support president Trump
you wanna know why I'm here to support
president Trump because they don't give
black men like this for decades make up
charges and put on so I know Trump is
innocent I support Trump against this
corrupt two-tier justice system that's
why I'm here to show my support as a
black man for Trump and I'm wearing my
shirt for Trump 2024 and I mean that
what do you think about the indictments
oh it's a bunch of bullets
around the country you know Phoenix
Fanny Willis she's a uh she went to
school with my sister she fully she was
full of so she's a puppet for the
white liberal and that is controlling
everything she's in front but the white
liver back there pulling those strings
telling her what to do
that's what I think about it making a
fool of herself do you think it's going
to help his election of course it is
it's going to elevate him all well I
think we should make Trump king that's
how I feel
[Music]
now we're just gonna make him King but
we still got our freedoms and rights to
everything he for that yeah Trump for
King 2024. this guy I'm not joking do
not think that I am in any way being
ironic this guy is smarter and more
insightful and has a clearer view of
political philosophy then 97 of the
chattering class probably more 98 or 99
his name's Derek Gibson he ran for
governor of New York I think he's
running for congress right now
this guy is smart
and he connects with people because he
is able to speak in a way that's
entertaining and so he can go viral
think about what he said there even just
at the end when he said I think we
should make Trump king and the woman
laughs and she is isn't that kind of
communistic and
all of a sudden the joke kind of stops
and he looks at her and he says wait
what respect
is being a king is communistic do you
not know anything about regime and
political philosophy who on Earth would
say that monarchy is communistic good
grief lady not everything that isn't
1982 style liberalism is communist good
grief
no what does he say he says no it's not
monarchies have existed for all of human
history communism's been around for
about 200 years uh no there are some
differences Communists tend to subvert
monarchies too by the way you know how
the Communists have overthrown a number
of monarchies or attempted to overthrow
a number of monarchies the Bolsheviks I
don't think I don't think that the
monarch of Russia I don't think Tsar
Nicholas said oh wonderful my fellow
communists come in and kill my family
what are you talking about
she says no it's not he says it's not
communistic we'll still have our
freedoms and our rights he'll just be
the king
and he he's joking obviously but he's
not joking about monarchy there have
been many monarchies throughout history
that are much more free and are much
better at protecting people's rights
then
supposed democracies
there have been many monarchies
throughout history that are much more
free that are much better at protecting
people's rights than our supposed
democracy right now
here's exhibit a they're arresting all
the dissidents and
lawyers simply for representing the
opposition leader who they're arresting
to
so Preposterous there's a very shallow
liberal view that the only kind of
regime that could ever possibly be good
or legitimate is
democracy in the year of Our Lord 2023
because a lot of these people say oh
even democracy 20 years ago it was evil
it was oppressive we didn't have all
sorts of rainbow Flags everywhere it was
awful give me a break
going back to polybius we know they're
they're good monarchies the bad version
of monarchy is tyranny but that's just
where the the one-man ruling is ruling
for himself rather than the common good
there are good aristocracies they're bad
as bad versions called oligarchy
and there have been perfectly lovely
democracies but there's a bad version
called mob rule where are we right now
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles is
your cell phone in Desperate native
replacement you know the signs short
battery life so you gotta have a charger
on hand cracked screen gives the glass
splinters it's time to put that old
phone to rest and upgrade to a new 5G
Samsung Galaxy from Pure Talk for free
get a free 5G Samsung Galaxy with 2 day
battery life edge to edge display
Ultra stronger Relic glass when you sign
up for Pure Talk's unlimited talk text
and 15 gigabyte data plan for just 35
bucks a month plus
comes with a mobile hotspot if you are
not using puretalk you are simply paying
too much get all the data you could ever
need for half the price of the big
carriers on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network go to puretalk.com Knowles for
your free super durable 5G Samsung
Galaxy when you switch to Pure Talk
visit puretalk.com Knowles and make the
switch to my cell phone company Pure
Talk the official Wireless partner of
the daily wire head on over right now
to puretalk.com
but then getting to the to the first
part of his political commentary Mr
Gibson's he says
when he's asked what do you think of the
charges here do you think there's any
Merit to the charge goes ah they're a
bunch of BS
that is the only response I want to hear
when the legal case against Donald Trump
is brought up because it's not a genuine
legal case none of this is being done in
good faith none of this is sincere it's
obviously a bunch of BS the proof of
that is one they don't ever prosecute
Democrats who even in recent memory have
committed much more egregious versions
of the supposed crime that Donald Trump
that Donald Trump committed but
furthermore
they'd get him for eating a ham sandwich
think they they impeached him for being
pro-russia allegedly they impeached him
for being pro Ukraine allegedly they
impeached it or they investigated him
for being pro-russia they they impeached
him for being pro-ukraine allegedly they
said that he's an insurrectionist they
said that he he
had an in-kind donation to his own
campaign by Sleeping with a porn star or
something they said that he raped a
woman in Bergdorf Goodman's 30 years ago
even though she fantasized about how
wonderful this would have been there's
no evidence that Trump has has ever
spent more than five seconds with this
lady
it's just such obvious BS and I just
don't want to hear it from the the
chattering class well
um actually you know if you look at the
case against Donald Trump uh actually in
paragraph four it says that he you know
he actually might we should probably
start imprisoning the political
opposition give me a freaking break man
check your clock and know what time it
is
give me I just don't want to hear it you
hear this from very serious people even
Bill Barr who I still have a
considerable degree of respect for at
least is a political thinker
political operator to say well this case
is serious in this case it's less
serious it's all a freaking Witch Hunt
man Molly Hemingway made this point you
know Stalin got his convictions okay
Fidel Castro got his convictions
Chairman Mao got his convictions
that they got their convictions through
show Trials of political enemies which
is exactly what we've got right now I
wish we could replace our Elite
chattering political class with Derek
Gibson leader of ninjas for Trump is
much more serious and clear-minded
thinker boy what a great clip that was
now
you gotta ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube show Channel
program
Comedy Hour we'll see you next time